what do you think about the 2024
election do you think donald trump runs
do you think the the tension
[Music]
will grow
um or was that a singular moment um
do you think you'll be like aoc versus
trump or whoever
whatever the most maximum drama
maximizing thing or will things
stabilize
uh i think i can i can
you know historians don't like to
predict the future but i can predict
this one that it will not be a calm and
and stabilized election
um i think as of you know the time that
we're talking in 2022 we don't there are
too many um you know sort of open
questions particularly about whether joe
biden will run for re-election he says
he will but you know but
the jury i think is out on that
um
you know i i can't predict whether
donald trump will run for for election
uh or not i think
you know we do know that that that
president trump doesn't like to
to start things he can't win
and if the polling data suggests that
he's not a credible candidate he might
be reluctant to enter the race and might
might find more appealing a kind of the
kind of sideline uh kind of king maker
role that he's been crafting since he he
left the white house
um
you know i think there are plenty of
people who are
uh
you know dreaming that there's some sort
of centrist candidate um you know uh you
know
whether it's a conservative democrat or
a liberal republican who will you know
save us from from uh from all of this
um either within the party or in a third
party run i don't think that's likely
why are we getting them why don't you
think it's likely what's the explanation
this seems to be a general hunger for a
person like this you would but the
system sorts it out right you know that
the
the primary systems and the party uh you
know party candidate selection systems
um you know will favor sort of more you
know more partisan views right more
conservative republicans more liberal
democrats
as the kind of center candidates
it seems like the system prefers
mediocre
executive mediocre leaders
partisan leaders
if i to take a cynical look but maybe
i'm romanticizing the leaders of the
past
and maybe i'm just remembering the great
leaders of the past
and uh yeah i can assure you there's
plenty of mediocre partisans in the 19th
century
and the 20th
you